السلام عليكم
لو فتحت على جوجل علشان نعمل سيرش احنا
واياكم مع بعض على كلمه النجاح
سعاده كلكم راح تلاقوا صور جميله على جوجل
ومنها مثلا هاي الصوره وانا واياكم بصير
نطلع هيك ونسهر بالليل
وعيوننا تتلالا يا سلام هذا الزلمه ناجح
او تفتح سوشيال ميديا وتشوف زي بشمهندس
شخص
متى بيوم من الايام انا بدي اكون واقف
محله
يمكن في كتير شغلات بالعالم احنا بنتفق
عليها وممكن نختلف عليها وحده منها هي
النجاح
لو بدنا نفكر مع بعض ما هي الشغلات او
الاساسيات كل واحد فيكم كل واحد بشوف
الفيديوهات
ايش يعني النجاح
يمكن فلوس اطلع كل يوم عشرين الف دينار
فانا راح اكون احسن شخص موجود في العالم
في ناس بحكي لك شهره وقف قدام جمهور واحكي
ويكون عندي متابعين هذا احسن نجاح انا
عندي في العالم
اسافر والله بعرف ناس بروحوا وبيسافروا
اروح على المالديف وبعد بكره اقوم
بالارجنتين بعد كاس العالم
حلمي
بعض الناس بيحكي لك الجاه سلطه يحطوني
مسؤول انا اليوم وزير التعليم العالي
هذا احلى شيء بحياتي
بعض الناس او بعض الناسات
اني اكون احلى واحد في العالم او احلى
وحده بالعالم ملكه جمال الكوكب
النجاح مختلف
خليني احكي عن الفلوس
ممكن اروح اشتري ساعه بعشر الاف دينار
بس هل بقدر اشتري دقيقه واحده
ممكن اروح اشتري احسن تخت في العالم واريح
فرشه بالعالم بس هل بشتري الراحه
ممكن اشتري احلى بيت في الكوكب بس هل
بشتري السكينه والعلاقات اللطيفه بالبيت
ممكن اشتري احسن جيمين كونسول هل بشتري
سعادتي
خليني احكي لكم قصه سريعه في يوم من
الايام
بدي احقق هدفي
خلاص قررت انا بهذا اليوم بدي احقق فيه
الهدف تبعي
وقبل ما احكي لكم القصه يمكن لازم نتفق ما
هو النجاح ففعليا هو اشي مختلف ولكن اذا
بتبحث بالعلم وجد العلم بانه النجاح اهم
بارت فيه هو تحقيق الهدف فايش اول خطوه
بالنجاح
انك تعرف شو هدفك ختم المهندس بمقوله انه
اذا انت بتعمل اقصى جهدك اعمل مور ودفنت
لصح ولكن
بالاتجاه الصحيح
مثال انا ماشي معين باتجاه الشمال
ناوي عند نقطه معينه اوصل على جوجل ايرث
بالضبط هون اذا باول الطريق كنت بس درجه
واحده باقه بس درجه واحده درجه واحده شو
يعني على اول سانتي هيك
لما توصل هدفك بعد اميال وين راح تكون
باخر الدنيا فتحديد الهدف هو الاهم علشان
انت تعتبر شخص ناجح والقصه بتحكي في يوم
من الايام كنت طالب طب في الجامعه
الهاشميه وقررت اعمل ريسيرت كان ايامها في
البلد مش كثير قوي فحطيت قايد او حطيت وقت
مع الجامعه بانه احنا بدنا نشتغل على مده
اربعه اشهر فانا حطيت المخطط زي ده كنا
لما ندرس بنجهز الغرفه نحط المكتب واللاب
توب ترتب الامور
بتصير تطلع على الدبان الغرفه بتصير تطلع
على المنظر اللي بره تامل في خلق الله كل
العبادات التامليه بتطلع في الوقت الدراسي
فمسكت الاجنده مع اني عمري ما استعملتها
جنده بس ما بعرف ليش اليوم مسكت الاجنده
وحطيت هيك رسمه زي ما انتم شايفينها اليوم
تبعي بعد 3 اشهر وراح ابلش بالشغل تبعي
اول يوم ساعتين الشهر اللي بعده خمس ساعات
شهر اللي بعده بحيث قبل باسبوع باسبوعين
من الورقه بكون خلص انا تعودت على الشغل
وراح اعمل احلى ورقه طلعت بتاريخ البشريه
هذا الجول تبعي
بس يمكن مشكلتي كنت شوي نكمل درجه مغير
المهم
العب كره قدم مع فريق الجامعه الو في
مباراه بكره تروح بروح في عرس لصاحبنا
تروح بروح في طلعه تروح بروح
الثلاث اشهر صارت
شهرين بعدين اكتشفت انه الدرج تبعي بدل ما
كان درج درجه راحت اول درجه فصار اصعب علي
شوي بس حكيت يلا شهرين ممتاز ستيل راح
اسوي احسن ورقه في العالم
مشيوا الشهرين اول اسبوعين ثلاثه كل يوم
هيك بحط اللاب توب بجهز الاجواء بعمل
القهوه نفس السيناريو وبعدين ببلش فقره
التامل
تطلع نروح نيجي بلاي ستيشن كره قدم
راحوا شهر ونص ضل اسبوعين وانا مش عامل
ولا اشي مش كاتب ولا كلمه
المفروض تكون 60 صفحه ما كتبته ولا كلمه
شمرت مره ثانيه ضل اسبوعين
حطيت الكتاب واللاب توب وعملت نفس القهوه
وعملت نفس التامل
الاسبوعين صارت يومين وبعدني مش كاتب ولا
كلمه
ولما عرفت او حسيت وشعرت انه بعد بكره
تسليمي احسن بيبر في العالم اللي انا
حاطها في مخيلتي والدكاتره
شو صار
خلال يومين ما نمت كويس كتبت الورقه عملت
زبطت عملت
بتجنن وركضت على الجامعه وسلمتها للدكتور
وروحت الامور تمام خلصت الحمد لله
بعد بيومين بحكوا معي الجامعه مرحبا كيفك
اسامه يعطيك العافيه كل شي تمام الحمد لله
انت كتبت احلى بيتر شفناها في حياتنا
[تصفيق]
طبعا هذا الحكي ما صار
حكوا لي شو المصيبه اللي عاملها
[موسيقى]
شو اللي صار
فيدباك نرجع هيك نعمل شويه رفلكشن انا شو
اللي عملته او احنا شو اللي عملناه
عاده بس يكون في عندك طبعا كلياتنا احنا
كبشر بنحب السهوله بالاشي الاسهل بنعمله
في طلوع درج او اسكليتر
يطلع درجة لمصعد مصعد في شغل صعب ومتعب او
امشي بطريق سهل بروح سهل كورونا قعدنا
سنتين الدكتور عمل اختراع واشتغل في ناس
ختمت نتفليكس وخدمت افلام واشتغلت
هلا عاده
في اشي بخوفنا
اللي هو
كلكم ليش صاحيين الصبح وجايين على الجامعه
كتير والله حابين تصحوا على السته ونص
الصبح واللي جاي من عمان ولا جاي من
العقبه
هو اللي بصحيك الستريس هو اللي بخليك تنجز
واللي يخليك تنجح هو العامل او الفيول
تبعك للنجاح اذا انت بدك تمشي باتجاه معين
بدك بنزين
فالبنزين تبع النجاح هو الاسترس
طبعا للاسف انه احنا كنا عايشين في منطقه
جميله طبعا ما حد يضحك على الرسومات هاي
رسوماتي رسمتها امبارح
كلنا عايشين في منطقه جميله على جانب الخط
الازرق هون
وين انت ساكن في بيتك مع اولاد وبنات
الحاره مع جاراتك مع اصحابك طول نهاركم
تلعبوا عندك سيارتك
قاعدين على التليفونات بتحضروا افلام
مسلسلات الحياه اللطيفه
اللي انت ما بتستفيد منه ولا اشي يعني انت
دائما مفكر لما نعمل هاد الاشي شو راح
استفيد والنتيجه ولا اشي هذا انت خلاص عم
بتضيع الوقت فاحنا اغلبنا مبسوطين هون في
هاي المنطقه علشان تشغل سيارتك وتمشي
وتوصل للقول تبعك اللي شايفينها بالاخير
بدك فيول واللي فيول دايما شو مرعب شايفين
كيف شكله هذا اكثر شيء صعب وبيخوف
بدك شيء متعب
في القران ستنا مريم وهي بتخلف
ربنا حكالها في القران شو حكى لها وهزي
اليك بجذع النخله
تساقط عليك رطبا جنيا
يعني ربنا بجلال قدره ما عند القدره ينزل
هالرطب
طب ليش وحده عم بتخلف وبالمخاض وبالصحراء
ولحالها وست ليش تهزت عن نخله عشان تنزل
عليها رطب
دائما في رساله باسوء ظروفك باصعب اوقاتك
بدك تشتغل ما في نار بدون دخان وما في
دخان بدون نار ما في حريق بدون شراره مرات
تشوف جبل ده كله محروق اوف مين حرقه والله
الجماعه كانوا بيشفوا مولعين هالقد نار بس
كبرت
هذا حكينا مشكله في ديد لاين في عنا
امتحان بدي ادرس له بدي اشتغل باجل باجل
باجل قبل بيومين ثلاثه بروح بدرس في دلاين
بس في مشكله تانيه
في شغلات ما الها ديد لاين في شغلات ما
الها نهايه
مثال علاقتك مع اهلك علاقتك مع ربك الكرير
تبعك
هي نفسها اللي شفتوا اللي كان الشاب قاعد
فيها وبلعب مع اصحابه من اجل ما تقدر تعمل
خلاص بكره بكره ما هو احنا صغار زهقونا
سبيستون لا تؤجل عمل اليوم الى الغطسه
الكرتونه شكله هون
فانا موجود عم بصحى الصبح باكل الفطور
تبعي امي عامله السندويشه باخذها بطلع
بالجامعه بطلع بالمواصلات وبوصل بروح على
المحاضره باخذ المحاضره بروح بشوف اهلي
بلعب بحكي مع صاحباتي بفتح انستقرام بسكر
بنام بس حصب وهكذا هاي صارتون ما في تطور
وزي ما انتم شايفين كل ما طلعنا برا
الكونفورد زون
خطوه بس ببلش مين يشتغل
اشي انا مش مجربه
اعطيكم مثال
قبل فتره قررت اني بدي اسوق دراجه
طبعا كل المجتمع كان ضدهم امي وابوي
ماسك دراجه ما بعرف
فقلت بجرب مره مرتين ثلاث والله في جبل
بدي اطلعه والله بدي اتعلم كيف بنطه والله
بدي اعمل باك فليب
هذا برا الكونفورد زون ادرينالين رش بخاف
في اشي راح يصير انا مش عارفه
بتعرفوا ليش احنا بنخاف من العتمه ليش
البني ادم بيخاف من العتمه
وفعلا مش ما بيخاف من العتمه الانسان
بيخاف من المجهول ولو اعمل معكم هلا تجربه
اربط عينك ومش شايف ولا اشي ووقفك جنبي
على الاستيج هون واحكي لك لف وجهك هيك
واغمض واحكي لك نط
هل راح يكون عندك الجراه انك تنط
ما بعرف لانه نفس الموضوع لو وقفتك على
حرفه هاي الاستيج او على حفه جبل وحكيت لك
نط فاحنا بنخاف من المجهول بس تاكدوا
تماما لما ما يكون في ريسك
سيء الواحد يكون مضغوط وهيك
ايه ودائما يلا بدي اعمله اسوي بس طلعوا
في البيك هاي اذا انت ما عندك ستريس
بالمره زي بحكوا مين اكثر ناس بيعيشوا عمر
اطول بتعرفوا مين اللي بيتاخروا على
موعيتهم عنده موعد على الساعه ثمانيه ونص
على الثمانيه ونص بتلاقيها بتحط ميك اب
طيب الناس بيستنوا عادي هدول اطول الناس
عمرا ما في ستريس عادي بيستنوا امتحان
بروح علي بقدم ميك اب العرس بده يروح
بنبعت له على البيت هديه في بدائل
هلا كل ما زاد الستريس بصير في اشي اسمه
الحد الفاصل مع النجاح انا بدي اشتغل
لحالي رح اتعب راح افشل بدك تنشر على
السوشيال ميديا نفكر كل الناس راح يحبوك
راح يهاوشوك
بدك تتحمل هذا ستريسكو انت عم تطلع من
الكونفوردون طب ما انا قاعد ببيتي وما بدي
حدا يقعد يبلش فيه هلا كل شيء فيه تعب كل
شيء في تعب بس بالنهايه في نتيجه ما بدنا
نوصل للاوفر ستريس بعدين بنصير عند نور
وبصير يتعامل معكم كطبيب نفسي بدنا
راح اختم بثلاث شغلات بسيطه اي شخص ناجح
في العالم في عنده ثلاث مقومات اساسيه
العلم المهارات
وشخصيتك العلم زي ما تفضل الباشمهندس قبل
شوي هلا فتره تجميع العلم يا جماعه كل ما
تدرس اكثر كل ما تلاقي اكتر كل ما في
ريسورسز اكثر كل ما انت بتستفيد
والمثال كثير حلو انه اليوم فعليا قد ما
كان عندك سكيلز في منافسه عم بعمل كمان
سكيلز اكتر فبدك كمان وكمان
غير العلم الاسكيلز الاسكيل زي السواقه
واحد ما بيعرف يسوق بده يتعلم سواقه بيروح
بياخد تدريبات بتعلم بياخذ الرخصه اول ما
ياخذ الرخصه كيف بسوق بتلاقيه سايق وخايف
وموطي الموسيقى ممنوع حدا يحكي في السياره
وحاط حزام الامان واحد لز عليه بزمر له
ولك شو بتسوي
بعد اربع خمس سنين تلاقيه بسوق باجره حاط
موسيقى وبحكي تليفون
وبياكل بوبكورن ومسغل مشغل اغنيه مين عم
بسوق السياره هاد اسمه العقل اللاواعي صار
اشي اسمه اوتونومي
صارت السواقه بالنسبه له سهله مع انه اول
يوم سائق سياره كيف كان خايف متوتر برا
الكونفور زون كبر الزون تبعته صارت من ضمن
السكيلز
احنا هلا موجودين في نقطه هذا العلم تبعنا
والخط الاحمر اللي شايفينه المحيط شو هاد
لا معرفه
فاحنا الدائره تبعتنا هاي المعرفه والمحيط
هو اللامعرفه
لما تتعلم
بالجامعه وتخلص وتاخذ دكتوراه وتسافر شو
بصير بالعلم تبعك بيكبر صح
شو بصير بمحيط الدائره تبعتك
تكبر اكثر واكثر عشان هيك كل ما تتعلم كل
ما بتعرف انك جد ما بتعرف وهيك بيحكوا
الانجليز دمور يوليرن ذا مور
وكل ما صرت تعرف اكثر واكثر شو بصير
بالدائره تاعتك بتصير اكبر والمعرفه تبعتك
لا معرفه بتصير اكبر
راح اختم بشغله
كل واحد فيكم هلا وبستعملوها هاي بالجرم
وبالمطارات وبالفيز لما تروح تعال بصم
اعطينا
شو الفائده من الفينجر برنت كل واحد فيكم
عنده بصمه مميزه عن التاني ما في واحد في
العالم راح تتشابه بصمته معاك انت شخص
مميز او بصمه عينك
بس السؤال الاهم من هذا انه انت ربنا حط
لك اشي اوريدي موجود عندك بصمه مميزه
بعد ما تروح شو البصمه تبعتك بهذا العالم
شو الناس راح يتذكروك لما لا انا احكي اسم
فلان هديل محمد علي
شو الناس بخطر في بالهم مين بيعرفوك ايش
الكلمه اللي بستعملوها هاد والله هذا
رياضي مشهور بيقدم محتوى لطيف والله هذا
شيخ كويس والله هاي بنت موهوبه
بهذا العالم
وبكره راح يصير عندكم اولاد وراح تحكوا
معكم هذا الحكي اكيد شو البصمه تبعتهم ولو
تغير واحد في العالم
هاي هي التيكون مسج من كل الدنيا انا بدرس
طلاب بالجامعه بحكي لهم اذا انقذت حياه
شخص واحد هذا هو المطلوب من كل اشي تعلمته
بالحياه وراح اختم لان يهدي الله رجلا
رجلا واحدا بك احسن من ايش خير لك من حمر
النعم وحمر النعم ما تملكه الارض كامله
وما يملكه ملوك الارض جميعا متخيلين
يعطيكم العافيه
[تصفيق]